sports now the golden knights have
advanced to the western conference
finals for the second time in three
years
but getting past the canucks was quite
the grind john treach is here now with
vegas on a rest day john
now imagine playing five of the most
grueling hockey games of your life in
seven days only for the reward to be
pressing restart
and doing it all over again against the
dallas stars that's the golden night
reality in the stanley cup playoffs game
seven was hard fought and glorious for
the golden knights but it is in the past
the golden knights and dallas stars
both played the maximum amount of games
in the western semis and nearly were
eliminated
they survived and are thankful they
don't have the wear and tear of travel
but that doesn't make the quick
turnaround easy game one is tomorrow
whether a team is ready or not
you know i i think everybody would take
a night at home
uh to get away from the environment in
order to clear your head i think that's
always healthy between ceres
uh you know unfortunately you know we
don't have that so you gotta
you gotta deal with the the mental piece
of that and try and get away
uh some way mentally you know today we
didn't do anything we didn't host
we didn't host any meetings we didn't
show any video we just wanted them to
to clear their heads you know as much as
they could in here
the nhl the knights will be without ryan
reeves for game one as he is suspended
for last night's illegal hit
coming up in sports coach peter deboer
gets into the dallas matchup plus the
raiders
make a few roster cuts that hit close to
home sasha